- Let's talk a little bit about
exocytosis,
which is how the cell is able to
release larger molecules
that might be used by the rest of the body.
Other cells, or maybe it's going to be part
of the extracellular matrix.
And to understand how this works,
it's really the reverse of endocytosis,
we're going to go
and produce some proteins
in the endoplasmic reticulum,
this is our classic example.
Those proteins are then going to bud off,
in their own little vesicles,
which then merge with the golgi apparatus
where they are further processed.
So they're processed in the golgi apparatus,
right over here,
and then eventually they're going to bud off
of the golgi apparatus in new vesicles,
and those vesicles are going to make their way
over to the cell's outer membrane,
the plasma membrane
and the membranes of the vesicles
are going to merge with the membrane
of the cell
and in doing so, they're going to release
their contents.
And this is classic exocytosis,
there are other cases
where maybe it
merges partially, releases the contents
and then buds back
is called the "kiss and run" method
of exocytosis,
but the classic one is
it merges with the membrane.
We can look at this,
this membrane
after the vesicle's membrane has merged
with the plasma membrane,
the membrane might look like this.
So if the vesicle,
let me do the vesicle's membrane in orange,
if the vesicle's membrane is at an orange,
well now it has merged like this
and it has released its contents.
It has released the protein
to be used someplace else,
someplace else in the body.
And I want to be clear,
this membrane,
and I talk about it many times
in many other videos,
even though I've drawn it as one line
right over here,
this is going to be a phospholipid bilayer,
so if we were to zoom in,
it would look like this.
It's a phospholipid bilayer.
So these are some of the phospholipids
that were part of the original
part of the original membrane
and then we also, in my little box,
I get some of the ones that are part of,
or that were part of the vesicle
that was holding that protein.
That were part of the vesicle
that was holding the protein.
So I really want to stress
I want to really stress these lines
that I'm drawing
these are bilayers of phospholilpids.
And all of these lines,
these membranes that you see,
these are all bilayers of phospholipids.
Just to make sure
that we are visualizing this correct.
And that's what exocytosis is
and one thing that I find interesting
is when you first learn about it
you see it diagrammed like this
and you just assume,
okay, well, these bubbles of these
with these membranes
they just randomly must float
eventually to the membrane
where they get merged
and then they release their contents.
But actually it isn't that chaotic.
They actually can sit on tracks
so they actually can sit on tracks.
Remember we talked about the cytoskeleton
which isn't drawn enough
probably because it makes drawings
really messy
but whenever we think about a cell
there's all this structure to it.
There's all this structure to it,
microtubules, microfilaments,
intermediate filaments,
all of these things over here
that not only provide structure to the cell,
but they can be used to transport.
And these vesicles
these vesicles can actually ride
on these structures
and you could actually have
motor proteins that are using ATP
to actively push the vesicle
containing its contents
so this is a kind of transportation.
It's really like a factory
to push them towards the membrane
so that they can be released.
So whenever I think about it, it's fascinating
'cause I always talk about these cells
being a universe unto themselves.
And they aren't just these blobs,
they have all of these structures,
there's all of these proteins
that are really on an unbelievably small scale
able to do these fairly intricate processes.
So what I just showed you, once again,
this is classic exocytosis,
you'll see it when you have proteins, lipids,
being produced by the cell
that need to be released somehow.
They're also famously used in
neurons,
the chemical signal,
when you go from one neuron to another,
you have exocytosis of neurotransmitters
that will trigger the next neuron.
So these are very, very important processes.
Our bodies would not function properly
or, wouldn't function at all,
if we did not have exocytosis.